[Musique]
des vikings dans la cour du château du
hohlandsbourg surprenant non pas tant
que ça les hommes du nord ayant mené des
raids dans toute l'europe
il est probable que vous lointains
ancêtres les ai croisés de ce côté ci du
rhin au 9ème et 10ème siècle seul
anachronisme le château lui-même qui fut
construit au xiiie siècle et n'a donc
pas croisé la route des peuples
scandinave
pour le reste tout est historiquement
exact
loin du folklore télévisuelle et des
casques à cornes il faut dire que la
compagnie du nord
invité par l'équipe du château pour
cette animation applique un soin
particulier
ces reconstitutions ça commence d'abord
par un gros travail de recherche dans
les livres entre autres on s'intéresse
aussi beaucoup à l'archéologie puisque
tout ce qu'on présente dans la mesure du
possible en tout cas est une
reconstitution fidèle d'un artefact
archéologiques y compris les costumes
les armes tous les accessoires les
outils on essaye également de présenter
les techniques d'époque
quand on les connaît lorsqu'on les
connaît pas on fait ce qu'on appelle de
l'expérimentation
donc on reconstitue les outils et les
contextes qu'ils avaient à l'époque on
essaye de les utiliser pour voir comment
ça fonctionne
ou comment ça ne fonctionne pas le
travail qu'on fait ce week-end donc je
faisais c'est un petit peu la fin du
travail c'est de présenter
l'aboutissement de nos recherches de
montrer au public comment vivaient les
vikings comment ils travaillaient
comment ils se battaient également
présenté leur vie quotidienne tout
simplement d'une façon pédagogique
puisqu'il ya des démonstrations
artisanales des démonstrations de
combats mais aussi des ateliers
participatifs pour les enfants ils
peuvent s'essayer à certaines techniques
comme fabriquer un filet de pêche
cuisiner comme les vikings mêmes manier
des armes faire découvrir l'histoire au
travers d'animations mêlant spectacles
et connaissances c'est l'objectif que se
fixent l'équipe du château
en toile de fond l'idée que ce haut lieu
du patrimoine alsacien devienne un lieu
où toute la famille pourra découvrir une
histoire vivante pour cette saison de
nombreuses animations sont ainsi au
programme
on a trois axes de développement qui est
tout d'abord l'animation grand public
avec des événements
tous les mois ce mois ci c'est la saga
des vikings le mois prochain ses
merveilles d'orient bien montrer quels
sont les échanges entre l'occident et
l'orient liées au commerce maritime et
tout cet été nous travaillerons sur
corsaires et pirates
nous avons un deuxième axe de
développement c'est tout ce qui est
pédagogique avec l'accueil de scolaires
et de périscolaire et à un troisième axe
le tourisme d'affaires avec l'accueil de
comité d'entreprise de petits séminaires
et de team building construit par
rodolphe de habsbourg pour assurer le
contrôle de la plaine d'alsace qu'il
domine le château change plusieurs fois
de mains avant de tomber en ruine c'est
à partir des années 70 que sa sauvegarde
est envisagé la restauration c'est à
elle de 1986 à 2014
alors c'est une propriété départementale
et qui a été restauré avec un
financement département et anciennement
région alsace il est sûr que ce château
participe au rayonnement de notre
territoire
ceci je pense à divers titres bien sûr
dans un premier temps dans le domaine du
tourisme puisque 10 qui dit château 10
route des châteaux et ainsi de suite et
donc déjà dans le domaine du tourisme
et quand on dit rayonnement ce château a
été construit à l'époque justement parce
que il permettait une vision de 360° sur
la plaine d'alsace et comme vous pouvez
l'observer on voit toute l'économie qui
est à nos pieds puisqu'on a aussi bien
de la vigne donc qui dit vigne du vin
on a nos villages on a la pleine avec
ses céréales
il ya la ville y à l'industrie et au
loin on a leur a donc on retrouve
vraiment tout ce qu'on a
au niveau économique de notre région qui
manque que la mer aujourd'hui ce joyau
haut rhinois accueille près de 60000
visiteurs chaque année
une manne que les élus du canton de
wintzenheim et
père bien redirigé vers l'ensemble du
territoire c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ne
faut plus garder jalousement un
patrimoine et espérer que les gens
viennent chez vous mais pas lécher les
autres donc on a décidé déjà depuis
maintenant quelques années et je crois
que ça se développe de plus en plus de
collaborer avec les autres offices de
tourisme parce que l'objectif c'est bien
sûr que les gens viennent un autre
château dans notre château mais
également qu'ils aillent visiter tous
les environs tout ce qu'ils peuvent
admirer à ici puisque j'ai parlé de 360
degrés avant donc là vous avez donc le
fond de la vallée de munster est pas
loin d'ici vous avez la maison du
fromage également donc l'objectif est
effectivement d'inciter les gens à aller
visiter ces lieux question patrimoine le
canton de wintzenheim a des arguments
quelques-uns des plus beaux cépages
alsaciens et la vallée de munster dont
il est inutile de préciser qu'elle fût
l'apport à notre région
mais c'est aussi des paysages
magnifiques propice aux loisirs nature
comme la rando ou encore l'accrobranche
nous sommes au parc aventure de la
station du schnepfenried ici ce sont 11
parcours à travers les arbres qui sont
proposées aux grands et aux petits
c'est un endroit où les enfants peuvent
s'amuser c'est des câbles tendus dans la
forêt c
des parcours qui sont à différentes
hauteurs qui vont permettre aux enfants
et aux grands même de s'éclater
alors nous on a pris l'option d'ouvrir
beaucoup donc en fait on est ouvert
pendant toutes les vacances scolaires
même en hiver vacances scolaires et les
week-ends et à partir du 17 juin on est
ouvert jusqu'à la fin de l'été nation de
sports d'hiver le snep est apprécié dans
toute la région et même au-delà
c'est important de valoriser en fin de
compte les sports de montagne
surtout que au niveau du département il
faut pas le cacher qui en fin de compte
est un partenaire important financier
par rapport aux sports d'hiver donc au
niveau des stations de ski
mais qui en fin de compte souhaite
effectivement l'étendre à aux sports
toute saison ça permet de faire vivre de
la station toute l'année on sache ont
également qui a de quoi se restaurer
avec ferme auberge il ya des gîtes etc
disons c'est une station qui est
vraiment dynamique en hiver c'est une
station de ski il faut pas l'oublier
puis en était en fait il ya des choses
qui ont été mises en place par le
syndicat mixe notamment un petit bail
par qui peut être utilisé par les
enfants aussi encadré par nous moi je
suis accompagnateurs en montagne avec un
brevet d'état
vtt on propose aussi du tir à l'arc
tout l'été des jours bien défini mais en
tout cas on peut proposer des activités
tir à l'arc et aussi comme on est
accompagnateur en montagne on peut
proposer de la rando l'été découverte de
la faune la flore les chamois l'histoire
locale
tenez le vous pour dit on ne s'ennuie
pas dans le canton de wintzenheim
d'ailleurs on vous y attend de pied
ferme